[Applause]
women's rights activists shed tears of
joy for years they've been fighting for
the right to legal abortion now
colombia's constitutional court has made
it possible
this is a big achievement for all women
we want a greater recognition of our
full citizenship more security over our
bodies and over our sexual and
reproductive rights
every year colombian prosecutors open
400 cases against women accused of
having illegal abortions or those who
allegedly help them
more than 340 women have been convicted
since 2006.
until now colombian women were only
allowed to terminate pregnancies in
cases of rape fetal deformity or if the
mother's life was in danger
but even those exceptions weren't always
respected
just in 2020 4 000 girls between 10 and
14 years gave birth pregnancies in
children that young can only be the
result of rape the only explanation for
such high numbers is that women needed
more protection that's what we fought
for
four out of five judges voted in favor
of extending abortion rights despite
opposition from the catholic church and
pro-life activists who prayed in front
of the court
the feminists believe this is a step
forward for women when in reality it's a
step backwards because the fight for
women's rights doesn't include murdering
others
president ivan was opposed as well
saying the decision is too big to be
made by five judges
by allowing abortions until 24 weeks
colombia's court has raised the bar even
compared to countries which have taken
giant steps to defend women's
reproductive rights
in most countries the time limit for
having an abortion is far shorter
in the meantime women activists say it's
not enough to have their rights on paper
they say they'll keep fighting to make
sure the law is implemented monika
yanakiv al-jazeera